have you ever stayed at an airbnb
perhaps used verbo well as you may know
they are illegal in unincorporated clark
county and commissioners want your
feedback crafting short-term rental
regulations because they have to be
legal bianca holman live with how you
can weigh in bianca this is important as
i said earlier does kind of pit neighbor
against neighbor in some cases
it does but that's why they're coming up
with the rules here at the clark county
government center there's going to be a
meeting here later on tonight and they
want you to attend because they're
formulating the rules that are going to
be in place this summer right now
short-term rentals are illegal but
that's soon going to change so assembly
bill 636 mandates the county and cities
of las vegas henderson and north las
vegas to adopt ordinance to comply the
bill requires the county to create and
implement rules regarding noise the
possible quiet hours or limits on
amplified sound so this is to of course
deter from spots turning into party
houses it would also put measures in
place around parking where guests could
park and having designated parking spots
and even if you're not a homeowner it
impacts everyone living in the valley
there's some mixed opinions about
short-term rentals in our community
obviously for people that
are renting out their house uh they've
got strong opinions and and want the
rules as flexible as possible so they
can continue to get some extra income
uh other people obviously you know have
issues with with short-term rentals
rentals coming into their communities so
they want strict regulation
so that meeting is happening at the
clark county government center starts at
5 30 this evening if you can't attend it
of course be streamed online and of
course coming up in the next half hour
we have more information on this meeting
that's happening tonight and also
there'll be one on thursday but more
detail coming about that coming up about
that in the next half hour bianca holman
live local now